c'è un tizio che ha finito tutto camerte
con il birthday di just dance è da tutti
ragazzi e benvenute che sono io sono un
po dj oggi o thomas direttamente a casa
mia in un gioco calmo questo questo 70
euro
noi glielo ripeto perché mediamente
l'intesta prima di iniziare alla ragazzi
siamo sul caffè si può giocari l'ha
cambiata in corsa per questo mosso già
fatto facciamo sì forse per bene siamo
partiti da dio come dicono che si spara
non c'è potere fantastico ma doveva fare
ma di melo e poi ci facevamo sparando le
altre cose tra i primi parla devi dirmi
anche cosa devo fare
milano l'idea allora pratica se inter e
le carote questo nome ma quando quando
muoio questo è importante ogni oblio
deriva di salto di tirarmi uno schiaffo
alle tiepide dire susciti presente che
passa sotto la cura con attenzione
perché ci credo ci credono di thomas ci
credo tu giorni calotte il mondo sia
prevenuto norma non mi sa che non sa già
che fino ad ora è stato avevo fatto
neanche unità
siamo quasi a metà delle morti
questa di tutti per lo stesso cervello
alla rete al posto di l'indice della
prima di dover fare anche ieri sa che
con questo la questione partito di
plastica barca sono stupido sarebbe
scusato subito che adesso basta un'altra
cosa adesso mi resta di grazie perché mi
sono state soltanto e di evitare i
rampicante possa partire dal cavalca
grandissima fare questo cosa strana
malattia che esploda l'attenzione passa
veloce un applicativo da meno si
sbarazza ci provo
credo in te sta bene thomas ocean si no
così tom a me non piace lordure sito a
me
d'alema sembra un po non se qualcuno si
sta sfruttando un'altra stanza grande
assente è stato due volte mi è saltato
pure 19 grado io non è questo b e cioè
il fotografico preso finora veniva
bellissimo ottimo il suo quasi manga
iniziata non sarei sito della tv ma se
lo facciamo noi possiamo comunque
a picchiarelli che aiuto a vendere ma
perfetto
credendo a bene io sono andato
esattamente dove stanno
un genio lo dirà distrusse ormai in moto
subito preso bene bene ciò che ha fatto
che se mangiate giacciano quanto ovvio
vabbè ma non aspettatevi ma il suo
verace continua e stato difficilissimo
dai squadra mi capito che metterai cosa
facciamo adesso
grazie grazie di gissi 0 ok ok ma mai
arrivare a saldo sulla fogna mena
secondo forse lo facciamo insieme un
ricava la croazia vado cosa è successo
come assetata addio promessa minaccia
vinto
non so no no no no no no no no non
scorda con un ignoto bravo bravo non
sopporta la donna da saturno
[Musica]
e bella occhio questo bravo
una due tre
[Musica]
oggi è considerato un assunto così a
casa dalla chiti la vita non l'ho vista
con la forme meno al 32 su roma
la mori dalla fascia h
siamo qua c'è un post a tensione possa
muovere per la possiamo stare bene
soltanto muoversi da una poi dell'altra
e lui non è facilissimo oppure un box il
livello è già un casinò si raggruppa
oltre 100 grace 21 vai a pau guarda
veramente se esiste un inferno nella
vita non è se non è questo io non posso
capire fare
direi di andare per l'ultimo post cita i
wine assolutamente breve bella
quest'anno a isola allora scegli per la
va bene questo questo dice di su garland
sì mi piacciono i dolci di sacco però in
questo caso mi faranno un sacri che
alzarsi dai regola problema vedere come
non lo so però lasciatemi scavata è una
tizia ovvero alle sue cose
sì allora son cazzi act ha studiato di
schivare di schivare i dubbi del nostro
amico aia porca vacca che fastidio a
quanti gli sul viso tirato e basta
ci sono già uno di vita ok primo andato
pensate sì ce ne sono tre di fila poi
c'è lei come mai questo è uno di quelli
conclusi ma stato un pochino
no no no no no no va bene ci provo
sono casuali poi guarda mi suona 0
eccola mentre a questo qua mi sembra il
meno peggio a tutti i primi tre cose
sono abbastanza 6 ma è pensate i
montaggi dice lei alla fine ha rimandato
vediamo da 59
ci sono cinque tipi di posti diversi che
cos'è cos'è facilissimo della madonna
canzano cos'è una sfera per la caramella
credo che ci sono no no no no non
avevano mai tranquillo stavo tutte
prende vita è ancora buono buono ma non
ha una sede a thomas però va bene ne
esce un altro il seno fagiolino di
passare sotto vediamo che la barretta di
cioccolato no vabbè investiva bile in
schiva bile rischi va col sentimento di
fruttato sfortune lo schifo e plancia
garante non c'è
tu sei sta roba
e adesso c'e lei ora ce l'aveva allora
mi mani su una caramellina e sta attento
perché tra poco ti lancia la schifo fare
il continuo a seguire quello perfetto
però questi vari gigante sami parco
schivano poeta non gioco che di crack
saga no grazie
dobbiamo restarci così è impossibile se
non basta mori che fastidio
sì sì sì sì o no adesso il nostro scemo
a chiedetemi la designer il fagiolino di
bazar muore ma non è vero non l'ho
pubblicato su quanto ci metta a morire
viene dato ormai certa sentito ieri ci
bastava guardarlo va bene così non
vogliono madonna parlamento per la
canaletta sale più veloce quando quando
morì volte occhio perché le 16000 note
di natura della super ibra a chiara sono
ma la cosa che non doveva succedere a un
mannaggia thomas ti prego io ti regalerò
un bambino con qualcosa da fare una
macchina che io lasci ti prego no quando
hai fatto
ma come i soldi è bancato di questo boss
non si vede trovarsi pagato solo di
questo bossi mi è successo non vedi
quanto quindi è un'incognita oro bakiev
attimo prima che lui torna perché perché
non capisco già la testa che mamma mia
che fastidio bruttissimo basta mi sono
fatto le palle
ok perfetto le elezioni quindi tre carte
con la super sta minkia se la testa
piatta maledetto spara di tombe 65 aveva
sbagliato ho fatto l'errore di calcolo
sbagliato i 13 13 credito che ci credi
scritto cosa sono morta sto provando per
fax christophe palazzo accaduto sono
diversi cd r certo non spara a zero nel
mio primo vero
distruggiamo la resisti resisti laurent
esisti tira tutto quello che hai di
rally in legno
io sono morte tutto questo ma le
edizioni con terminali ma procediamo più
nostra super metalsistem di tra l'altro
puoi vedere aspetta adesso vediamo il
tipo che lo faceva con la settimana
voglio laser e scarso strade capace più
forti da pochissimo dai ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto ringrazio per avermi
accompagnato thomas e hall e mick mi
sono sembrati bravi mi sia piaciuto a
cose ci siamo mi piace passate anche dal
canale di al quiz che trovate nella
descrizione dove si chiede e noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo vita dell onore
di più delle cose da ragazzi
io so che tu sei un dio che ci
distendiamo giuro devo davvero se vai
dicendo sul serio mai
[Musica]